merci beaucoup d'être en direct sur rt
france tout d'abord une question pour
vous 10 naba diop
vous vous faites partie du parti
socialiste lyne réaction à la victoire
de dani d'algos à paris nous sommes
évidemment ravis de conserver paris ce
fut une belle campagne
anne hidalgo a été soutenu c est une
belle récompense du travail qu'elle a
menée durant le mandat précédent et nous
sommes heureux de gagner aussi avec les
écologistes et donc d'avoir fait un beau
rassemblement de la gauche y est vous
êtes actuellement 1 1 marseille
marseille qui est en passe aussi de
basculer c'est le printemps marseillais
n'est français ce soir
oui j'y crois très fortement et cela
pour encore une fois que lorsque la
gauche il rassemble et elle est capable
de d'être aux responsabilités et de
gagner largement
je pense que c'est aussi ce que nous
devons retenir de ces municipales c'est
que c'est le rassemblement de la gauche
qui fera qu elle continuera d'avoir des
responsabilités et surtout qu'elle
retrouvera une place importante dans le
coeur des français
on le voit avec ces élections
municipales la gauche reprend des
couleurs
les partis traditionnels finalement ne
sont pas morts quand comme on l'a cru en
2019 avec les élections européennes
oui tout à fait et je pense que c'est
surtout on montre en fait ici que l'élu
de proximité qui est un conseil
municipal que le maire garde toute son
importance et qu'effectivement la gauche
et les partis dits traditionalistes sont
loin d'être enterrée au contraire ils
ont une carte à jouer mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que elle doit être
rassemblé et c'est aussi aujourd'hui la
victoire d'une gauche différentes qui
s'allie avec les citoyens et les
citoyennes ou celle ce fort taux
d'abstention est préoccupant c'est ce
qu'a dit jean luc mélenchon ce soir il
dit que c'est un danger pour la
démocratie
oui je rejoins les commentateurs
évidemment lorsqu'on est responsable
politique est d'autant plus lorsqu'on
est élu local
on ne peut que s'inquiéter de
l'abstention grandissant commandes
atteint un taux historique et
effectivement il faut à ses yeux c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut reprendre
on ne peut pas ignorer que 60%
d'abstention il ya un vrai malaise
démocratique dans notre pays
et effectivement je pense que cette
défiance envers la classe politique est
en grande partie due aux à ce
gouvernement qui a manqué à sa promesse
là celle d'une république exemplaire
celle d'une république qui écoute les
gens se sont sentis délaissés abandonné
voire même maîtrisé par le pouvoir en
place et ça se traduit malheureusement
par une non seulement un décrochage
important de la république en marche
qui de toute façon ne l'avait pas
d'ancrage local et ça s'est vu lors de
ces élections municipales mais aussi par
une abstention record
parce que les personnes qui disent que
ça ne vaut pas vraiment la peine de se
déplacer aux urnes et c'est vraiment
très préoccupant ou c'est pas la crise
sanitaire c'est pas la peur du virus qui
a fait que les gens ne se sont pas
déplacés aujourd'hui il y a de cela mais
je pense que aussi prendre en ligne de
compte le fait que vous avez vous avez
eu des mouvements sociaux assez
important qu évoqué tout à l'heure
l'autre invité moi je pense qu'il ya
deux facteurs il ya la peur du cours
d'un violent parce qu'on nous a répété
pendant des semaines et des mois que
c'était un virus mortel qui ne fallait
pas à sortir de chez soi
et même si effectivement dans certaines
grandes villes les gens reprennent le
cours de leur vie normale vous avez
encore beaucoup d'endroits où les gens
n'osent pas sortir où les gens
continuent d'être ruiné parce que ils
ont peur d'avoir comment dirais-je une
seconde vague
quelle quelle est votre réaction quand
on voit effectivement que pour la
première fois depuis 1977 martine aubry
n'a pas fait alliance avec les verts
d'abord pour quelles raisons et est ce
que sont les verts vous pouvez toujours
gagner je parle des prochaines élections
évidemment escoder les alliances ou une
refondation est nécessaire selon vous
pour les alliances se sont ce que nous
avons c'est ce qu'a été en fait la règle
pour ces élections municipales nous
avons cherché à la faire partout
malheureusement il ya certains endroits
où les verts ont décidé de partir seul
et c'est dommageable parce que cela
provoque
une fois que lorsque il y a de la
division c'est la gauche qui est
perdante
je suis évidemment très heureuse que
martine aubry conserve la ville de lille
nous en aurions été bien plus d'un
heureux si elle avait pu la conserver
avec les verts mais je pense que ce
qu'il faut retenir surtout c'est que le
parti socialiste a fait l'alliance
partout où c'était possible parce que
nous sommes intimement convaincus que ce
qu'il faut c'est un bloc de gauche il
faut un bloc de gauche qui souhaite une
alternative à une sorte de il n'ya pas
justement de choses qui soient écrites
on a voulu nous faire croire que nous
avions le choix qu'entre le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche
force est de constater que par exemple
le gouvernement en tout cas le parti au
pouvoir a été sévèrement puni puisque il
prend une sacrée des routes
donc à nous à la gauche que nous avons
la responsabilité en tant que partis
traditionnels est aussi important que
partie historique de continuer à
chercher l'alliance de la gauche partout
où c'est possible et de conforter ce
bloc de gauche justement vienne diop
olivier faur premier secrétaire du ps
lui parle d'un blog social écologique
qu'il faut maintenant consolider sa
passe par où selon lui ça passe comme je
voulais déjà dit par une ailleurs sa
plus large possible à gauche de toutes
les forces de gauche et bien sûr des
écologistes je pense que c'est un bloc
qui en manquent cruellement aux français
et c'est un bloc qui a été du coup
plébiscité par les français ce soir
parce que la gauche réalise un peu
partout un bon score et les socialistes
qu'on avait trop vite enterré résiste
très bien
nous avons aussi deux belles victoires
notamment à marseille je pense que c'est
emblématique de ce que peut faire la
gauche lorsqu'elle est rassemblé quand
vous dites la gauche est ce que ça
comprend la france en soumises
bien sûr il faut il n'y a pas de bonne
ou de mauvaise gauche
pour moi le blog
de gauche et un est en soi quelque chose
qu'il faut rechercher et donc nous
feront alliance avec toutes les forces
de gauche
à chaque fois que c'est possible